speaking from the grounds of the royal
castle in warsaw poland u.s president
joe biden forcefully declared russian
president vladimir putin must go
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
it sounded like a major shift in u.s
policy previously u.s officials
including the secretary of state antony
blinken have denied the united states is
seeking regime change in russia from
this location on nato's eastern flank
biden also addressed the russian leader
directly
calling his invasion a strategic failure
and warning him not to expand the
conflict don't even think
about
moving on one single inch of nato
territory we have a sacred obligation
under article 5 to defend each and every
inch
of nato territory for the full force of
our collective power
[Music]
earlier in the day as biden met with
poland's president he reiterated as a
member of nato the u.s and its partners
will defend poland if it's attacked
poland shares a more than 500 kilometer
border with ukraine already more than 4
million people have fled ukraine with
more than half seeking refuge in poland
as biden met with mothers at a makeshift
refugee center set up in warsaw's
national stadium he reiterated his
belief that the russian president is a
war criminal for allegedly targeting
civilians you're dealing every day with
vladimir putin
look at what he's done to these people
what does it make you think he's a
butcher
also on saturday biden met with
ukrainian defense and foreign ministers
who had made a rare trip out of ukraine
biden pledged support for ukraine's
sovereignty and characterized its
resistance as a battle for freedom that
may be a long fight
the white house denies president biden
was calling for regime change in russia
but instead says he was arguing that
vladimir putin cannot be allowed to
exercise power over the region still
biden's message was unmistakable
that russia's war in ukraine is a battle
for democracy the free world must fight
kimberly hellcat al jazeera warsaw